So I'll begin.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, although I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassa
homage to the buddha the blessed door and fully self-awakened one yeah i'm just glancing there make sure my microphone's on okay very good so uh this evening
I'm going to tackle this discourse, number 20.
It's called The Removal of Distracting Thoughts.
Now, this is very specific.
The Buddha's up in Anathapindika's park again, Jeta's Grove.
And he tells us in the first line what this discourse is about.
When a bhikkhu, remember bhikkhu means all meditators, is pursuing the higher mind from time to time, he should give attention to five signs.
what are the five so this discourse is really for people who are wanting to attain jhana the absorptions but there's a lot here which will do for vipassana practice too so keeping that in mind yeah so now when you're practicing you know concentration obviously you want to stay on the object so it's always
Generally speaking, good practice to begin with the breath in Vipassana and just to wait for that settlement for the mind to become fairly still.
What my teacher used to say, Sayadaw Janaka, somewhat steady, right?
Somewhat steady.
We never knew exactly what that meant, but you get the idea of it.
And often when we go to sit, of course, there's something quite loud waiting for us, you know, some, some,
Anger, some anxiety, some overexcitement or something.
But sometimes when we sit, there isn't much there.
And if we don't watch it, the energy of the meditation rises.
And before you know it, you're off into fantasyland.
So it's good to start with a little bit of concentration meditation on the breath.
Yeah, just watch.
Just get the feel of it, watching it, feeling it rising and falling.
Okay.
So now giving attention to some sign and owing to that sign that arising in evil, unwholesome thoughts.
Now, in the jhana, you would have something to center on.
So the breath, sometimes a circle of color, sometimes metta and metta practice.
So you always have something that you're going to develop your concentration on.
To make it easy for us, we'll just stay with the breath.
There are 40 of those objects, by the way.
But just to simplify things, we'll just stay with the breath.
So he's watching the breath.
You're watching the breath.
And there arise unwholesome thoughts connected with desire, with hatred and delusion.
So you should give some attention to some other sign connected with what is wholesome.
So in other words, displace your attention somewhere else.
So there's a long note on it at the back.
from the commentaries, and it says, hold on, I've got the right number, 240, here we are.
So thoughts of sensual desire arise directed towards living being.
The other sign is foulness, right?
So any desire that you have towards a human being, if you see the foulness of that human being, that undermines such desire.
when it's the thoughts directed to things inanimate objects then to see their impermanence so if for instance you're you're sitting there and and you suddenly think about your next mobile phone that you want to buy then just recognize that in fact you know mobile's phone mobile phones arise and pass away not worth spending too much time on it
When thoughts of hate arise, you know, directed towards living being, then the other sign, of course, is meta.
And when it's designed to other objects, like a hated noise or something, then just go towards the elements.
What's the actual basic feeling?
So it might be that you're annoyed with some noise coming from next door or something.
And then if you go to the ear and just feel what you're actually experiencing, that takes away the hatred.
Now, when it talks with delusion, it says to live under a teacher, study the Dharma, inquiring into its meaning, listening to the Dharma and inquiring into its causes.
So the problem with delusion is, of course, the person doesn't know that it can be a bit of a problem.
So that's the first remedy.
If when you're trying to still the mind, there's a lot of agitation there.
Just give it the opposite of what is making you agitated.
So take, for instance, a lot of anxiety and your mind goes off onto this worry, this constant worry.
So you can counteract the underlying mood by bringing to mind peaceful memories, memories of being in a country, memories of being in a park, etc.
It'll work so far.
So, and as always, he always gives a metaphor for us to make it understandable.
With abandoning of them, this mind becomes steadied, internally quieted, brought to singleness and concentrated.
Just as a skilled carpenter or his apprentice might knock out, remove and extract a coarse peg by means of a finer one.
Okay.
So there you've got a nice little image.
So that's the first remedy, you might say.
The second one, while paying attention to some sign, to some object, see the breath, what is unwholesome, there arising in evil unwholesome thoughts connected with desire, with hatred and delusion.
So now, if they come again, as it were, then one should examine the danger.
These thoughts are unwholesome, they are reprehensible, they result in suffering.
And when he examines the danger in these thoughts, then any unwholesome thoughts, of course, should fade away or at least be undermined.
And here we have a lovely example.
Just as a man or a woman, young, youthful and fond of ornaments, would be horrified, humiliated and disgusted if the carcass of a snake or a dog or a human being were hung around his or her neck.
So that's recognizing that if you think about the consequences of unwholesome thoughts, then of course they're not so attractive and one wants to get rid of them.
Then while examining the danger in these thoughts, there still arise in him evil thoughts.
So if that doesn't work, then he should try to forget those thoughts and should not give attention to them.
So in other words, just taking your mind away from it and come back to the breath.
Just keep coming back to the breath.
Just make no effort to be there.
And again, he gives us an example.
Just as a man with good eyes who did not want to see forms, in other words, to see what they were looking at, had come within the range of sight, would either shut his eyes or look away.
So that seems a little bit more easy actually than the others, but that comes as number three.
That's the third one.
So obviously, if you're trying to settle on the breath and the mind keeps wandering off on some angry thoughts, some irritation you've had, then just to, as it were, push it to the side.
Now, there's a distinction here between suppressing something, which you would do with anger or fear,
and parking it by just putting it to the side and saying, I'll deal with it later.
Okay.
And that can be a very skillful way, especially in ordinary daily life when you're at work or something, or you're on a bus or you're on the tube and some obsessive thought keeps coming, you know, then just to come in, feel what the cause of that obsessive suffering is, the emotional state,
And just talk to it and say, no, look, I'm just going to put you to the side.
You stay there.
I'm going to park you.
And I'm just going to pay attention to the rise and falling of the breath.
I just keep doing that.
Just keep, just keep gently putting it to the side.
That's not the same as suppressing or out of fear or anger, because that's, that's negative energy that you're piling on top of the already negative energy, the turbulence.
Okay.
So while trying to forget those thoughts, there's a bit of an impossibility there because, of course, every time you try to forget something, you remind yourself of what it is you're trying to forget and therefore unwittingly reinforce it.
So don't try to forget anything, just put it to the side.
Perhaps forget's not the right translation.
And then still, you know, thoughts come and invade the mind.
Then they should give a stilling to the thought formation of the thoughts.
Now, what the commentary says is that this means you inquire.
I don't quite know how they make that out from that statement, but that's what they say.
See, stopping the cause of the thought, this is accomplished by inquiring when an unwholesome thought is arisen.
What's it cause?
what is the cause of its cause, right?
So here, of course, in Vipassana, we would go to the heart and feel the emotion, the mood, the mental state that's actually driving this pattern of thoughts, you see, and you'd stay there and wait for it to pass away, right?
You know, just some planning, you know, constantly planning about something, something you've got to do, got to do, got to do.
And when you come off that and come down into the body, into the heart center, and you feel the agitation, the excitement, for you to stay with that, stay with that.
So this is the cause, this is the cause, and just let it slowly die away.
The example he gives is, just as a man walking fast might consider, why am I walking fast?
What if I walk slowly?
And he would walk slowly.
Then he would consider, why am I walking slowly?
what if i stand and he would stand and then he would consider why am i standing what if i sit and he would sit and then he would consider why am i sitting and what if i lie down and he would lie down by doing so he would substitute the grosser posture for the subtler posture so you're constantly uh
inquiring as to what is the cause of this of these obsessive thoughts right distracting thoughts it's put here the title of the of the discourse is the removal of distracting thoughts but i think often our thoughts are quite obsessive not only just distracting okay so that fails so now they're still arising among wholesome thoughts connected with desire with hatred with delusion then
with his teeth clenched and his tongue pressed up against the roof of his mouth he should beat down constrain and crush mind with mind sounds terribly violent doesn't it sounds terribly violent teeth clenched tongue pressed up against the roof of the mouth he should beat down constrain and crush mind with mind
The example he gives is of a strong man sees a weaker man by the head or shoulders and beating down, constrain him and crushing.
So with his teeth clenched and his tongue pressed against the roof of his mouth, a meditator beats down, constrains and crushes mind with mind.
So what would that mean in practice, you see?
Well, basically, that's mantra, right?
And of course, it's not quite as violent as the language gives us.
I think what the Buddha is trying to give us through this seemingly violent language is the real commitment, you know, to stop the mind from wandering.
And mantra is one way of doing that.
So the mantra of, say, may all beings be happy.
You'll know the Tibetan one, Om Mani Padme Hum.
there's any little phrase which for you has some meaning and one keeps repeating it and repeating it with attentiveness with attentiveness repeating it and repeating it and as the mind becomes concentrated then of course all the hindrances are slowly suppressed right they're not healed they're not they're not cured uh they're slowly suppressed and of course then the heart begins to sing with it a certain type of um
beauty a type of feeling which is elated and beautiful caused by concentrating the mind so that's one purpose of mantra so remember this discourse is about achieving jhana so now as vipassana meditators um you might use you might use mantra just to bring that sense of calmness especially may all beings be happy uh may they be you know free of hatred
What is it?
May you be safe, well and happy.
May you live contented in harmony with the world.
And just by generally just going through that, you see.
Some of you will know the Christian Jesus prayer.
I can't remember it now, but you'll find that sort of mantra in all religious forms.
And it has this benefit of making the heart grow.
But remember, it doesn't do anything with the hindrances, with the defilements that are in the heart.
That's what the Buddha discovered, and that's what, of course, is the purpose.
It's not the purpose, it's the consequence of doing vipassana.
The purpose of vipassana is to see the three characteristics, impermanence, cause of suffering, not self.
But as we do that, of course, the heart is purified.
That's the magic of the system.
So then, of course, he repeats these five ways of overcoming obsessive thoughts.
He gives attention to some other sign.
He examines the danger of the thoughts.
He tries to forget those thoughts and not give attention to them.
pays attention to the stilling to thought formation stilling of the thought which is the inquiry and then finally teeth clenched and his tongue pressed against the roof of his mouth he beats down constraints and crushes mind with mind he's become a little obsessive for me that phrase so then the bhikkhu is called the master of the courses of thought he will think whatever he
whatever thought he wishes to think and he will not think any thought that he does not wish to think in other words he's now in control of his mind of his thought mind of his of his imagery he has severed the craving flung off the fetters and with the complete penetration of conceit has ended has brought an end to suffering so uh in this sense this also leads to uh liberation uh by way of
undermining those thoughts but remember that that's not the whole story okay but eventually uh the purpose of our practice or the consequence of our practice is of course that you have complete control of your mind you don't think the thoughts you don't want to think and you only think the thoughts that you want to think now when this uh when the blessed one said this uh the bhikkhus those who there were satisfied and delighted in the blessed one's words
So don't forget this little book.
I think you've, it's probably back to front, is it?
Pressing Out Pure Honey by Sharda Rajel.
And you can download it as a PDF.
I don't think it's printed anymore, actually.
There's not a printed copy, but then of course it's not needed.
I'll try and put that on the website.
And what it does is it just like here on that particular discourse, just a nice little notes for you to read, keep in mind, you see.
So it's like you could read this before, read the discourse and come back to this.
And that would give you the understanding.
So that that is the discourse on how to overcome distracting or obsessive thinking.
I can only hope this will be of use to you.
and that it will not drive you to despair and that you will by your practice attain full liberation from all suffering sooner rather than later so we can do a little bit of practice what was that i hope seems okay good i keep i keep forgetting to look at the screen there